the first person to survive a trip over
Niagara Falls was Annie Edson Taylor in
1921 on her 63rd birthday she crawled
into an oak and iron barrel and floated
right over the edge of the falls
Taylor performed a stunt for money and
fame but she didn't earn much for her
feet
nonetheless Daredevils seeking to follow
in her footsteps were not deterred
in 1928 for example Jean lucier went
over Niagara Falls in a 182 centimeter
Rubber and steel ball lined with 32
inner tubes
lucier survived the fall and spent the
rest of his life selling souvenirs to
tourists
not all the Daredevils were as lucky as
Taylor and lucier
in fact of the 16 people who've tried to
beat the Falls just a little more than
half have lived to tell the tale